the Joe Rogan experience I did little
David Lemieux smashed him a pieces job
ya see what Abel Sanchez said that when
you when he turns to the right what
happened was the referee was because he
was turning to his it's left to get away
from the right hand he was exposing his
back and he did hit in there he was
worried about getting a point taken off
so the referee would have called them on
that yeah that's ridiculous
yeah you should be especially if the
referee was as bad as the judge well
there was one sweet lady yeah very nice
lady like lassies like that like missing
man she was responsible for some wacky
ass [ __ ] decisions you lose a lot and
no one does anything about what worthy
of a man boxing when she did it in
Holyfield yeah yeah wasn't she a part of
the whole Pacquiao Tim the fox's name
yeah
wasn't she part of that I don't know I
know I think she was part of the I think
she's the one that give Canelo the draw
against Mayweather when he goes yeah
yeah I think she should be fired
that was close very nice lady again very
nicely Stevie Wonder world of that's
just crazy that she gave Canela dragons
Mayweather I mean he got [ __ ]
schooled in that fight masterful yeah
big time in London
but not much that wasn't interesting
well in his defense Mayweather drained
him down to like wood yeah down one [ __ ]
yes okay they caused that you know that
no they said well we'll fight you at 152
Allen della be went okay cuz he said we
was gonna do it 154 and they says we
don't care what Gill down to 152 and
they went Thanks what our study mistake
he just left herself wide open
themselves yeah yeah he was seriously
sluggish in there yeah yeah well he may
makes anyone look sluggish though don't
it to be fair yeah he does man he's
amazing like what Floyd is able to do
like his control of distance and his his
understanding of what you're gonna do
next is so incredible yeah like you see
him pop a jab and then before the guy
even throws the right hand he's like
dawn yeah and the right hand passes him
he pops with a left hook and he's out
there yeah he's like [ __ ] I knew what
you were gonna do it did not work
Marchetti did that was a pop Timoney
we've gone round back of him before I
even realized some great things with a
Robert Robert Robert Guerrero yes we've
got a boxer in England called Josh Kelly
have you seen him yes yeah you guys have
a lot of great boxes over there now me
obviously you have the world champion
Anthony Josh yeah you hear the UFC is
gonna offer him five hundred million
dollars one if that's real weight I
wonder if it's real Joshua versing in
Ghana with me and poor job is someone
going to sleep Jesus Christ
I yeah I mean Francis is a great MMA
fighter but he's been fighting for five
years yeah he just hits [ __ ]
unbelievably I can't believe that you
said he'd go under in 20,000 she's like
120 something I think that's so crazy
wow that's so crazy that's what I get
with a kick you legs that carry her
around all day guys up I'm only hundred
behind him yeah well you know in his
defense he's a hundred pounds heavier
than me with just what in the [ __ ] his
hands are so big every time I shake his
hands I'm like how is that a person I
mean it's like it's like shaking hands
with a brick like a giant brick they're
just so big I've got a little baby I'm
just well they probably crush my [ __ ]
huge dude man
I mean and we were talking before about
how his in his background he worked as a
child in a sand mine digging shoveling
all day just all day digging sand like
what a what a great workout that is for
your bodies all stories ridiculous all
I'd say we're almost [ __ ] with five
years ago five years ago my sign for UFC
title yeah and came real close that's a
great if anybody else other than steep a
steep a so [ __ ] tough and skilled and
kept away from him but you saw what he
did to Overeem k1 grand prix champion
dream champion Strikeforce Heavyweight
Champion
Francis put him into orbit is that
meta-chem off his shoulders - ridiculous
and you could see the way over he was
fighting them Tuesday yeah any moment is
this it 129,000 161 I got 150 what was
it 152 - that was today though
the other day I got I was super [ __ ]
happy with Tyrone Spong what's the
former previous record 114 he's got one
twenty nine thousand one hundred sixty
one with a punch
I got 152 today [ __ ] but that's with
his arms man I mean that is it's it's
possible to really over emphasize how
[ __ ] crazy that kind of powers with
you it's gonna be bigger than my legs or
to be fat oh yeah no I get the mind like
say my legs well a guy like that I
believe Francis is 33 I mean imagine if
it caught him when he was 25 yeah you
know I mean imagine that guy it's like
that's what you were saying before it's
when you get a real champion